je vous dis vous êtes le créateur de la
première machine à café pour VTC on a
une petite vidéo regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une super idée petit à petit on
essaye de trouver
on est un peu tous inventaire ou créatif
ça peut arriver donc je fais VTC et avec
tous les clients qui viennent et qui
sont à peu près c'est tout bon bah ils
ont fait boire un café mais ça se
renverse donc le problème c'est c'est ça
et du coup à force je me suis dit bon
ben pourquoi pas mettre une machine dans
une machine à café rajouter un couvercle
qui se met par dessus pas mal ça veut
dire en même temps qu'on demande la
machine à café on peut demander court
plus long
à tous les cafés qu'on veut et là on
peut rajouter juste un couvercle et qui
se pose par dessus et au moins comme ça
on le passe au client et le client est
plus satisfait au moins il le renverse
pas c'est pas mal parce que je
m'attendais pas à ça j'ai vu la vidéo
c'est pas mal et vous avez commercialisé
ça en pré des professionnels en 2023 ça
marche bien pour vous aujourd'hui non là
c'est en création c'est derrière 90% que
c'est ce que vous en pensez vous
honnêtement je je me demande
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai inventé des formats télé mais
j'étais dans les nuages j'ai entendu une
fois deux fois trois fois
une machine à créer le pourcentage des
conneries c'est peut-être que vous vous
aurez un coup pourcentage plus élevé
[Applaudissements]
visiblement ça vous rend nerveux le café
oh
c'est pas que le café qui me rend
nerveux de la saison c'est les gens qui
ont un pourcentage des conneries plus
élevées que la moyenne
ça prouve quand même que vous avez
réussi dans votre vie comment vous avez
tellement foiré dans votre vie
[Applaudissements]
pour que vous compreniez mieux
une fois deux fois trois fois comme vous
les jeux je vous souhaite franchement je
vous souhaite de réussir
un peu d'argent et voilà donc un coup ah
vous avez eu une répartie ça vous a
suffi vous voulez une machine à répartir
aussi
[Applaudissements]
je peux faire des machines pour Monsieur
Castaldi c'est quoi les machines
comme tout ce que je viens d'expliquer
et comment vous vendez le café dans
votre VTC et ça peut aller dans 1 euro à
2 €, ça dépend si il est court ou long
ah parce que dans la gueule ça change
pas le tarif
donc il est refermé au moins c'est bien
vous cherchez des investisseurs
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'il a pris les moyens c'est
bien parti
[Applaudissements]
vous le connaissiez avant de venir non
mais je vous entends parler je n'entends
rire et puis il trouve ça nul donc moi
aussi je vois que ces jeux étaient nuls
donc
c'est ce que vous avez dit non et vous
voyez pas l'intérêt vous trouvez ça nul
non bah vos jeux aussi ils étaient nuls
non
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'impression de gagner pour
voir
voilà donc moi je vous franchement la
vérité un petit thermos la tête là que
ça va vite que ça au début
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai construit grâce à un thermos au
début mais comme les cafés ils se
renversaient et ben alors pourquoi on a
un filtre pas dans la machine à café
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
merci merci à nous dire oui la jalousie
est un mauvais défaut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez travaillé vous avez fait quoi
quand votre vie
j'ai commencé à travailler à l'âge de 18
ans voilà vous êtes là à rester là deux
phrases
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr un plateau pour dire que vous
avez inventé un couvercle franchement
c'est bon ça suffit arrêtez vous êtes
une mascarade de concours en épine
franchement
j'ai pas compris si ça marche
[Applaudissements]
Hervé en tout cas vous votre invention
est top j'essaye de faire quelque chose
c'est bien pas comme certains
[Applaudissements]
merci vous voyez pas l'intérêt ceux qui
ont investir
tu es arrivé chez toi c'est trop bien
mais c'est la machine
c'est la machine qui met le couvert j'ai
pas vu ça sur la vidéo
90% de test là et après on va arriver à
100%, il y a un bras qui met le
couvercle
tu as vu
franchement c'est l'invention de dingue
[Applaudissements]
non merci pour l'invitation ça me fait
plaisir c'était très gentil de votre
part sauf à Monsieur Castaldi encore une
fois bonne chance si ça peut vous
rapporter de l'argent tant mieux pour
vous moi j'aurais toujours rêvé de
gagner de l'argent en inventant un truc
donc
vous avez compris ce qu'il a dit non
pas à ce qu'il dit à chaque fois je
parle pas assez fort
[Applaudissements]
bon courage pour votre machine à café
et vous êtes beaucoup de courage et
beaucoup de chance et si vous cherchez
une égérie pour votre machine je peux le
faire
[Applaudissements]
non non merci
[Musique]
allez merci en tout cas Hervé penaud
Hervé Hervé
merci Benjamin je voulais te dire
Hervé c'était très agréable on peut
faire une danse on peut faire une danse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la machine à café